good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone's having an amazing day and i'm
smiling on my face because i just
realized like i think today is a day for
chili you think i mean they just started
their rain the weather i did check the
weather app and they said cloudy with a
with a chance of chilling yeah which is
my personal favorite weather forecast i
agree it did start to rain as i was
walking in i was getting some drops on
my thoughts yeah which was exciting
i could see a chili happening today i
really really could i'm just saying i'm
putting it out there not just for us but
for all of those who
really kind of crave like a chilly
moment yeah no you guys this might be
our day i don't have all the ingredients
mostly
i actually have the meat and that's
really for us like being kosher if you
have that you can get everything else
like at the grocery store but you have
to call the kosher butcher it won't come
till you're saying we have the meats
no i'm saying
two things one i just want to say ben
drove me to work today because we still
we have the car because yesterday we
borrowed ben's parents car to film i
think our best work yet i've watched it
three times and it's almost an hour okay
so i watched it while editing it then
before i exported it i watched it again
because i was like i don't want to have
to make cuts because it's gonna take a
while to export because it's so big and
then i watched it once it was published
and i have to agree with you and
everybody who we've sent it to and i
mean the toasters have and the patreon
members have seen it like are saying our
best vlog yet i watch it again this
morning while doing my makeup and i was
just like
hysterical laughing it's honestly such
premium content like we went finally on
our exams in the making a year in the
making we did our fast food mukbang vlog
we took the car we went to new jersey
that means cream and we went to three
fast food restaurants we won't spoil and
we tried the menu items that we were
craving and that we're able to try but
we saw fit
we stuffed our faces
stuffed i was having crazy belly
problems the whole day after you know
what i really wasn't and actually
the fullness was so fleeting like two
hours later i was like i wish i finished
that by the way when i was re-watching
the vlog and i was looking at all the
nuggets i like put down because i'm like
i want to get two full [ __ ] i should
have brought them home with me i was so
upset by the way we took two bites of
everything like two bites of the
frosting i ate that burger besides
burger we had two bites of the frosty
two bites of the sundae like we didn't
even finish a mcflurry like what were we
doing no you get so full so fast on that
food but it's not it doesn't stick with
you because it's not like good it's not
sustainable it's not nutritious there's
not really like an integrity of the meat
would you say there's not an integrity
of the calorie by the way that's just
like an inside joke from the vlog so
it's up on our patreon that was our
fourth episode for this month it has
been so long awaited and honestly i
wouldn't have done it any other way like
i think it's so premium yeah and it's
almost an hour and it's just so [ __ ]
good so check it out it felt like
filming a reality show honestly because
we had like the dash cam camera and we
were just like sitting there like kim
and chloe we were literally like in a
range rover with gopros like i was
feelings really feeling myself and i've
never in my life like itched for a
reality show it's actually something i
promised i would never do but i don't
know just like sitting in my car where
like you know those mounted gopros are
at such a flattering angle because
they're like a high above plus you get
like the natural light yes our lighting
is so good i was thinking i'm like this
might be for me yeah no i agree we will
definitely i mean the mukbang people
were loving it i think eventually we
should do another one going to
the ones that are opening on the strip
you if you watch the vlog you know i
don't want to spoil but there's so many
more fast food chains out there waiting
to be reviewed by us 100 and then i
think like well you're pregnant now so
like maybe after like you're good and
ready like we have to do a west coast
mukbang because there's like carl's jr
in and out del taco like there are so
many west coast and then maybe we do
like a southern regional like we do like
a whataburger there's just so many and
this is something i can definitely
you know franchise
exactly yeah no that's a really good
idea but and i agree we should wait till
west coast till i'm fit to travel yeah
but um
i do like doing it while pregnant
because i'm doubly hungry yeah yeah yeah
you know yeah so i had extra room so the
other thing i was gonna say was like ben
i could not fall asleep last night i
don't know i had so much on my mind i
have so like i'm now in the phase of my
life where like a tour is coming up and
i have nightmares every night about the
tour like last night i had the craziest
stream ready
i got to my show and like nobody told me
that it was like actually a variety show
and there was like all these different
acts and like
nobody told me how much time i had and
like dave chappelle was there and like
it was just like a nightmare and then so
random in my dream batsheva from
unorthodox life was like talking [ __ ]
about me to all the other comedians and
like i had to confront her it was a very
bizarre dream um
so whatever i couldn't sleep but i was
like a little grumpy this morning like
i'm entitled to be grumpy it's the
morning what else are you supposed to be
so ben picked me up and i was like i
wasn't even being mean i was just being
like quiet and he's like just on the car
ride here just like commenting on my
temper you know he's like are you grumpy
i'm like it's the morning like can i
just sit in silence oh jesus and then
like when he dropped me off i was like
being nice because i'm saying bye to my
husband who i love and i was like giving
him a kiss and then he was just like
commenting on my temper again like oh
you're so positive like this this is all
wrong jackie i was like so irrationally
angry i got out of the car on the
passenger side and i left the door open
that's funny so ben had to get out of
the car like in traffic and close my
door i was just like wanting to
i just want to feel justified like in
that he was being annoying right sounds
annoying to me i really don't like it if
nothing's like tangibly bothering me and
i'm waiting for you to ask what's wrong
so i can tell you what you did of course
but you know there are other times where
i'm just
it's called a mood it's not even a mood
it's the morning i'm tired like you fell
asleep at 11 ben i didn't fall asleep
till two i agree no that would really
bother me like just constantly being
commented on like my state of mind no no
no it's nobody's business no oh no no no
no no no it's nobody's business i guess
that's why you know your husband
shouldn't drive you to work i know but
it was so convenient especially because
the second i stepped out of my house it
started to rain and i would have walked
and i was really grateful for the for
the ride so i put up with the uh with
the commentary yeah um we have a
literally an amazing show for you guys
today that's gonna be six hours long
because we've got the fast five stories
which are we do so important no and
they're
meeting party yeah party
and then we have a little tv recap
because i watched so much cable
television last night that i'm just
dying to talk about and then it's
tuesday so we have deer toasters which
is our advice segment which is really a
highlight of my week yeah so that's what
we're gonna be doing today that's what
we're gonna be tackling i think we
should get into it you know the only
thing that we really did yesterday was
mukbang so if you wanna see what we were
up to head over to patreon.com morning
toast not only do you have the mukbang
of a lifetime waiting for you but if you
join today then you have so much content
waiting for you like it could get you to
next year and also
if you watch the mukbang from yesterday
you'll really see like you know behind
the scenes of what it takes to film a
successful mukbang it is stressful it is
you never see that side of it you know
on the other channels those youtubers
like the the those l.a crabs who like
sit in their car and eat and talk to the
camera like that looks like a dream job
it does
and it was incredibly stressful there's
so much trash that accumulates like the
traffic finding a good parking spot it's
a lot
yeah it's a lot plus you got to give it
your all you know well and i believe we
did i believe that we did so
patreon.com morning toast you will not
regret it so much premium content there
and then you can also request the videos
in podcasts that you want to see from us
that's true you know we everyone has a
voice there at patreon we i think we
kind of launches patreon with like as an
initiative to give a voice to the
voiceless and i think we've been
successful in that we've achieved just
that
so without further ado
moment of silence
missy do miss you bro
it is time for the fast life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today is brought to you by one of
our favorite sponsors making a return
third love we put our bodies through so
much pushing them to the limit for sport
family fashion or just plain fun and
when you think about it it's pretty
incredible that our bodies keep up and
third love is here to keep up with your
body and third love if you've been
struggling
to find a bra that fits a bra that
supports third love is the brand for you
like
bra that fits can change your your whole
life like you can change how the way
that your clothes look on you the way
that they fit the way you feel the
support the back pain especially you
know if you're a big breasted woman like
many of us are and especially in
pregnancy like these titties are
changing the third love is keeping up
with the changes so here's what's so
great about their love first of all
their sizes they have bras available in
exclusive half cups they have underwear
loungewear activewear and sizes extra
small through 3x and
for like most of my life up until i took
the third love quiz i did not know what
size boob i actually was and they have a
really really detailed quiz it's like a
personal shopper they focus on size
breast shape current fit issues and your
personal style to find bras and
underwear that are perfect for you
they've helped almost 18 million women
find their true bra size and that's like
the biggest value add of third love like
the size i never even knew my size
existed also don't sleep on breast shape
because you do your quiz which you love
you just feel so seen and heard and they
have all these different breast shapes
and you really feel so seen you're like
oh yeah that one looks very familiar
yeah i know her third love is also the
largest donor of undergarments in the
u.s partnering with organizations across
the u.s they've donated over 40 million
dollars worth of bras to help people in
need and there's just like not a reason
that you shouldn't be shopping at third
love um and we also have a code so
that'll help so right now you can get 20
off your first order at thirdlove.com
toast that's 20 off at thirdlove.com
toast i've been wearing third love bras
since they became a sponsor and it's
truly a life-changing brand like this is
why we do what we do 100
first story another reason why we do
what we do justice for the girls has
been served our kelly has been found
guilty on all counts in sex trafficking
trial
ooh flag r kelly was found guilty on
monday of sexually abusing women boys
and girls for decades capping the 90s r
b superstar's stunning fall from grace
the crooner was convicted on all nine
counts against him including
racketeering and violations of the man
act which prohibits the transport of any
woman or girl across state lines for any
immoral purpose
kelly who was wearing a blue suit and
white mask sat stone face next to his
lawyers as the verdict was read he faces
10 years to life in prison at his
sentencing which is scheduled for may
4th 2022. oh that's in a long time
this may
but like we know he's guilty like why
can't we just sentence him today
i never understand that
me neither seven months
well you know what
this is just a fab you never know you
know
like
with these types of situations there's
so much evidence and for some reason
like nobody ever goes to jail you know
like i always think of kevin the kevin
spacey situation like one day like boom
the trial was just over like
so the fact that justice was served is
so beautiful stunning and smart and i
don't know i just feel like we've all
been along for the ride
and you know what that documentary was
i feel like i don't know how the legal
system works but i feel like the
documentary was so instrumental in this
happening like it brought so people were
obsessed with that documentary and it
brought so much light to the r kelly of
it all yeah i agree i wonder how it did
affect the proceedings but it definitely
also garnered a lot of interest which
puts more pressure on
like
the
judicial process yeah and what's so
crazy is i remember when watching the
documentary like legal proceedings have
like started but he was stalling so much
which it is your right to a fair and
speedy trial but like if you and your
lawyers want to slow it down then like
you can and i just feel like it's been
such a long journey with such a
wonderful result and
i am very much looking forward to
justice being served and it has been
served and that is cause for celebration
and it's a it's a celebration yes are
you ready for our next story which is
just some really surprising surprising
news and i need you and myself to help
dissect okay what i'm seeing
angelina jolie and the weeknd are
fueling dating rumors i know with
another dinner in l.a so
they were spotted together once in june
and then they were spotted together
again at an italian restaurant giorgio
baldi in santa monica which is a
romantic restaurant it was a date
and they arrived separately but they
left together after a couple hours
inside okay i think this is so bizarre
like for a million reasons to me the
weekend is like the coolest guy in
hollywood like he's like just everyone
wants to be his friend everyone wants to
like make music with him he's like cool
cool cool like only dates like you know
young models like he's just a very
specific type
and how i perceive angelina jolie is
like nobody in hollywood really likes
her and she kind of just gives me like
what's the right word to use here
she gives me like
like she's a witch do you know what i
mean
not in like a
mystical sense but i feel like she's a
witch like she's a wicked person i don't
know why i just get that vibe from her
and the weekend is like this cool guy
everyone wants to be friends with like
talk about opposites attracting again
that's just how i perceive the situation
okay interesting i
also think this is a bit of a mismatch i
i never got witchy vibes necessarily and
i feel like for so long we got like cool
sexy vibes and then there's been a real
fall from grace with her divorce the
divorce and like brad is like the most
lovable guy
and there's definitely bad blood um
and i just
they must be going into business
together there has to be some sort of
project ben affleck there has to be some
sort of project on the table for sure
yeah i cannot wrap my head around this
it seems so random like you just pick
two celebrities
who work like in different industries
have different friends like i could how
do these two even meet like for real i
don't feel like angelina just like lives
in like a chateau in italy and like
never leaves it's beyond strange it's
beyond weird like and i'm sorry i do not
ship
no i don't ship either and but i do i do
always like to be surprised you know i
feel like
everything is so calculated these days
nothing is really it's true i don't
really see a headline i'm like shocked
i'm like what are you guys writing about
right now like this is nonsense so it is
nice to feel like i saw something that
like you didn't see coming it's nice to
feel something is what you're saying and
it's nice to be a part of something well
i just like got like a watery eye are
you getting emotional over this
beautiful matchmaking i am because love
is a beautiful thing oh my god are you
okay are you actually crying no i
something went into my eye oh okay i
feel like it might have been that fly
that had been swarming
wait also
i just find it crazy that selena gomez
will have dated the same person as
angelina jolie
sure is that like a crazy part no not
for me why
it just isn't they're just like first of
all like not to be you know rude like
the age yes so for those wondering she's
46 he's 31.
it's not that crazy but he able to see
31 15 years she
is 46 oh i thought she was much older
maybe because she's so mature
yeah she's definitely she's like very
involved in like the u.n you know like
she was giving me like 55 vibes but
she's 46. yeah no she's 46.
never knew no it's not the age
difference isn't that crazy
i just think they're it's just like
the weekend is just like so cool like he
has a song with kanye you know
but i think for a lot of people i i
you know angelina jolie is so cool you
think yeah she's like you know
megan fox like she was well megan fox
and i think for us who read like the
tabloids every day like
we see her for what she really is which
is witchy
totally but for most people like when
you think of like sexiest woman alive
it's angelina jolie so literally yeah
yeah i mean i used to think that like
back in the mr mrs smith days i just
feel like she's so low-key and then she
just like
i don't know like she stopped being like
that girl and then she was like
you know
philanthropist humanitarian world
traveler i think for a lot of people
she's that woman now
and they look at this and they're like
go weekend it's your birthday got it she
gives me like
like for me
i don't know i can't really put into
words what i think about the situation
like i told you it was it was gonna
baffle us okay cause like for me this is
like one stump okay
we have been stumped
because when i think of angelina like
she gives me a similar vibe to amal
but amal doesn't have that witchiness
like amal is kind of like this ethereal
like
woman of the world
where it's like angelina's that but like
with a cloak of darkness i can't explain
like does anybody know what i understand
what you mean because like she wore the
blood and like made out with her boy her
brother but
and she's just always like wearing like
black frocks i don't know
the difference between them is a mall is
a famous humanitarian right
and
angelina julie is the famous person who
became a humanitarian yeah you know it's
like the activist
literally i don't know why i maybe i
need more time to ruminate on this i
haven't given much brain power but i do
need time to like come to a conclusion
on why this feels so odd to me and like
why
i could see like angeline okay i could
see this is gonna be mean but i could
see angelina like you know wanting to be
with the weekend but i can't really see
the weekend wanting to be with angelina
does that make sense yeah i
the words you said made sense
i don't see it for either of them or i
see it for both of them i think it's
equal levels oh my god there's a fly
there's that fly and you know what i
think it should have just killed it well
i think it's because
you think if i turn around right now
there'd be some sort of infestation i'm
i'm looking at the bottom there's
definitely something going on we talked
about what's been going on with mick
plant in the mukbang if you guys want to
check it out at
patreon.com there doesn't appear to be
anything nefarious going on with the
plant well there does appear to be
something nefarious going on overall but
i just think maybe after this show it's
time to to say goodbye yeah
should we do a little
funeral for mcplant and do a vlog
i completely agree okay mcplant
you were there for me when nobody else
was
you literally and figuratively had my
back you gave us life mick planned and
we didn't do the same and we took it
away amen
are you ready for our next story
yeah i would say that i think that you
are you look ready
you have your caller it's actually a
dicky but thank you
okay
snl announces who is and isn't leaving
the cast yeah well yeah
so here's what's happening everyone is
staying except for beck bennett
and lauren holt
so
when i read this i did have to google
who lauren holt was but yeah i have a
photo for you which i feel like means it
was her time she just did not leave a
lasting impression
her debut was just last season that's so
sad i guess it just wasn't a fit but it
must be so hard to
make an impression first of all in such
a big ensemble cast
be you're not she wasn't a featured cast
member she was like there's two tiers
like featured cast members and then like
the cast and she was on that and like
i'm sure you can write and pitch but not
every one of your sketches is going to
get picked up some of them get cut for
time so it must be so hard to
like
stand out um and she just did not so i
think that her
being let go was probably the best
choice i was surprised by beck bennett i
mean i don't like die for him and i
don't think he's that great but he's in
every sketch you know what okay i don't
i just
for to put some respect on his name like
he really
is a
an important person on the show he plays
like he can do any impression everything
and he's really in every sketch yep he's
never the star it's never like what's
bec doing not everyone can be the star
no and he's just like a really strong
solid completely aggressive person and i
think that his absence will be very much
felt i agree i thought this was kind of
weird like well i mean maybe he has some
other opportunities i think that he's
been on for a while i think that you
know this isn't so crazy because people
have to move on at a certain point
sometimes you you get so big at snl
that you know then when you move on
you're like tina fey yeah but other
times like it's just a one step and then
you're going to take your next step and
he's been in some movies and stuff
yeah i've seen him around let's find out
his well the interesting thing about
this news was like i remember at the end
of last season we thought a lot of the
cast members were leaving like cecily
strong at the final episode of last
season was like very emotional i thought
for sure her time was up and i do think
her time is up a lot of people thought
kate mckinnon would be leaving and she
was not which is wonderful i think
nobody really thought keenan was gonna
leave because he's just like the the
stable figure that we all need
um and he really is in every single
sketch so
the the big time people nobody left pete
davidson is still on michael che colin
jones no only those two left so really
it's not it could have been more i
thought i remember having a conversation
at the end of last season that they were
gonna like clean house yeah but they
didn't and what they did do is promote
chloe
are now series regulars which as opposed
to like that second tier that we were
just talking about which i think is
fabulous yeah makes a lot of sense and
then they brought on three new comedians
aristotle athari james austin johnson
and sarah sherman wonderful can't wait
to see what they have to offer i do
think that chloe feinman and bo and yang
are the future of
the franchise so love to see respect
being put on their names and can't wait
to see what they bring to the to the
writers table yeah i think overall it
could have been a crazier shake up it's
not i think i will miss back ben and i i
think he's really funny and he always
understands the assignment always he's i
feel like he's like a very hard worker
like kept his head down like did exactly
never
was atrocious like never was the best
but like never really flopped never no i
think i i completely agree with your
assessment of the situation so
good luck back bennett good luck out
there yeah godspeed looking forward to
seeing you i looked at his imdb he's
been a lot of animated things so maybe
he's got some in bruins he does have
like that kind of voice
yeah no he's very talented he is are you
ready for our next story
yeah lisa vanderpump is making headlines
because her show premieres tonight what
show is it is it the winner from rules
oh i know somebody told me that
yesterday i actually know i keep telling
people that i want to double check
somebody told me that yesterday because
i was on live and they said are you
going to watch pump rules tomorrow night
um and is it just me or they've done no
promoting yes today okay cool season
nine episode one well that's exciting
yes why aren't they promoting it at all
i saw some stuff but i just assumed that
like when they announced that the show's
coming it's going to be in five months
so i right i didn't get excited i just
saw a trailer like one or two weeks ago
but no commercials like nothing yeah no
commercials just like from following law
lives right okay well anyways lisa
vanderpump is drumming up some interest
in herself by saying that kyle richards
spread erica jane rumors at andy cohen's
baby shower party so in a recent
interview with daily mail tv lisa
reluctantly claimed that it was former
bestie kyle richards who spread the
rumors about erica jane's financial woes
at andy cohen's baby shower in 2019.
so camille grammer had previously
claimed on twitter that a west
coast-based housewife and good friend of
erica's circulated stories about erica
at andy's star-studded party
when asked who it was lisa said it could
be the person that might that ken kicked
out of my house
kyle i just don't believe this one
because if something is coming from
camille donatashie grammars myers's
mouth i'm just
i'm reluctant to believe it she's so
thirsty and we know she has this like
very weird alliance with lisa vanderpump
um
so i just feel like this is something
they concocted in their heads to
maintain relevancy when both of them are
so irrelevant now
interesting i don't know i agree like
you definitely have to consider the
source i think lisa
if she could take anyone down with her
it would be kyle like i think she's mad
at all the girls but if she could
really get only payback for one house
like it would be kyle because i think
the betrayal is the deepest there for
her
so
yes you have to consider that but then
also
when you say stuff publicly like this
like in an interview like you don't
necessarily lie like
i don't know like who's how do there's
no proof that this is true
i don't know i could see some other
housewife popping up there were so many
women there no i'm saying i heard that i
overheard that she said that to me
someone to corroborate her story yeah so
i guess we'll wait for that i do like
and also what was she saying you know
she could have been saying something
that wasn't nefarious but just true that
you know tom is in a lawsuit he was
always in a lawsuit kyle is not stupid
like let's say kyle knew
i don't think kyle would be running
around this like housewife bravo event
talking [ __ ] about a cat like i just
don't know kyle's stupid i think that's
one extreme version of what happened
they're giving us nothing about what she
actually said or doing i don't think she
was running around saying anything maybe
she had a conversation with someone
one person and
she just mentioned tom's legal woes
because he had uh like just like doritos
i don't think kyle knew about you know
widows and orphans yeah oh no
yeah
so
i don't think it was that extreme but i
think she might have mentioned something
and now camille is like making it bigger
than a mouse but that's a very good
assessment of the situation i i feel
that so it's neither this n either
things are true neither things are false
did you see that andy went on jimmy
fallon and said the real housewives of
beverly hills reunion is going to be not
one not two not three but four parts yes
and i know i'm supposed to be jazzed
about i am
you're jazzed jackie first of all i just
they have to make up for those new york
time slots that they didn't sell that's
possible but i think first of all
there's like
so many things going on there's the
erika jane of it all which really needs
like two episodes like there's so much
and then there's also the other [ __ ]
going on and it's a pretty good season
like i think that four is definitely
extreme but i'm very i'm gonna have to
see what they give us first andy was on
watch live with sutton and they were
just talking about it like they both had
this trauma that they like lived through
going through the reunion and i think
it's going to be premium and you know
what i would rather watch a four-part
drawn out beverly hills reunion than one
part new york reunion
agreed and i'll i'll be open-minded just
keep in mind that means we're gonna be
recapping beverly hills reunions for a
month no i know that's insane insane and
i better get the answers that we deserve
and the justice that i'm looking for you
know what you know i should have
screenshotted it i saw this post like i
just follow all these like random bravo
accounts i saw this post that somebody
posted on reddit and it was just like
their thoughts on this whole situation
and it was so well said
like can you imagine if this situation
was going on with a housewife in a
different city like this person
basically wrote like imagine if there
was someone on atlanta who went through
this like kenya would be chewing her out
nene would be inviting the victims to a
dinner party if this happened in new
york bethany would get to the bottom of
it in 10 seconds literally erica jane is
so lucky that she is with this group of
like honestly wussies like who will not
ask a question and the only one who asks
literally even the most like
modest question is getting chewed out
like erica has no clue how good she has
it because if she was on another
franchise with some of these other
sleuth megan king edmonds
imagine what these women would do to
erica like if they knew the magnitude of
what was going on
and we're filming with her like so the
fact that she's having a [ __ ] [ __ ]
fit temper tantrum over sutton just
saying i don't want to be sued like she
doesn't even know how good she has it
agreed it was such a well-said reddit
comment comment which is so
rare i was shook yeah no i agree
completely so i hope someone [ __ ]
lays into her
union yeah even if erica is completely
innocent and has no blood on her hands
we have to be asking hard questions and
currently we're not
and we're all like yeah sutton when
something's like lucky doing nothing
like she's not even asking hard
questions
no but she's older than everyone else
right
i agree
i agree so if the reunion doesn't give
us that i'm going to be really [ __ ]
disappointed and you know what like andy
has given me little to no faith that he
will actually take matters into his own
hands when he's spoken on on the erica
jane case on radio andy and on watch
robin's live he's so like cautious and
nice about it and
i just don't think and then you know if
the monique of it all is a precedent
yeah we're getting we're getting that's
not a man who serves justice no we're
getting nothing [ __ ] and you know what
i've been like on this andy cohen like
downward spiral and if he fumbles the
ball on this reunion i'm letting you
know like it is the nail on the coffin
it's going to be a turning point for me
if he fumbles the ball on if if the
whole show fumbles the ball in this
reunion and we don't get like the
justice and answers and the questions
that we're looking for like
next season of beverly hills for me is
up in the air and you know what like up
in the air when i think of how hard
everyone was like the housewives and
andy at reunions on teresa when like
theresa definitely committed crimes that
were victimless and that really were
perpetrated by her husband and she's
just like
not the smartest right but everyone like
came for her so hard like we need that
energy times 11 right and i just don't i
don't have faith that we're going to get
it but i don't want to be negative i'm
going to keep an open mind but i'm just
letting you know if we don't get it
things are going to change around here i
completely agree thank you i'm glad
we're on the same page and that page is
brought to you by bowling branch bowlin
branch started with a mission produce
the highest quality sheets in the market
and make the world a better place in the
process and today they're still the best
choice for anyone who wants comfort that
lasts their signature hemmed sheets are
beloved bestsellers for one good reason
they get softer with every wash they're
buttery soft lightweight and they're
made in 100 organic cotton sateen weave
it's perfect for all seasons they come
in a variety of colors and sizes they
stretch from twin to california king
they're also made with toxin-free
process and a fair trade certification
to ensure workers are paid a fair and
living wage so i just have to say i've
had bowling branch since before they
were a sponsor because i did a swipe up
on rach parcell's instagram story and it
was the best decision ever i'm very
particular about my sheets one because
sheets have a big impact on your hair
and skin and because i'm a very warm
sleeper and i just feel like not every
sheet brand is catering to my sweaty
neck and bowl and branch is their
temperature cooled they're so fabulous
and they're gorgeous because you know
you got to have that reached parcel back
you gotta to experience the best sheets
you've ever felt choose bowling branch
you can try them worry free for 30
nights with free shipping and returns
and our listeners can get an exclusive
15 off the first set of sheets with
promo code toast at bowl and branch dot
com that's bowlin branch b-o-l-l
end branch dot com promo code toast
thank you claudia just wanted to follow
up on something i spoke about yesterday
i have made the decision to go see
olivia
i know i'm i honestly i think that was
part of the reason that was keeping me
up last night i'm so excited i'm so
jealous she's like obviously planning
and by the way we you told me that you
had to take off friday which really was
like the the thing that i was like okay
well now i have i can go thursday yeah
so i'm spending thursday to sunday with
olivia and michaela and zach and i'm
just so excited olivia's like i'm gonna
make a nice shabbat we're gonna go to
the club for dinner and i just don't
even know i'm bringing my bathing suit
like i just feel like
are you you might not be coming back no
a hundred percent like i'll make olivia
podcast with me like all week and next
week like oh and i think i'm gonna vlog
for the patreon like my whole trip but i
also want to enjoy so like i might
forget but i'm gonna try um i'm so
[ __ ] excited like that was what was
keeping me up last night like i missed
the kayla ashley shapiro so much
i'm so jealous i know like i'm seriously
so jealous i have a nice weekend lined
up for myself and brew but
oh you're bringing bro yeah bruce is
invited so nice it's so cool
asks
it's just more about the plane like i'm
traveling by myself that's a lot yeah
that's a lot he's a big boy
big boy big boy and he's them boys and
he's making noise on a plane and i'm
sitting in coach because literally it
was crazy no flights everything sold out
and so expensive wow and the airlines
have zero respect no human beings let
alone animals these days good luck to
you there are no animal rights on planes
anymore you actually discussed it so
crazy how all the airlines got together
and said [ __ ] these animals no they
literally were like oh where's peeta on
this yeah
like it's so crazy they just woke up one
morning and decided
like at first they tried to kill our
pets throwing them in the overhead bin
in the cargo space oh and like that
wasn't enough to get people to stop
bringing their pets on planes fine we'll
just ban it they tried to make it so
that we didn't want to bring our pets
anymore by making it unmanageable you
know you land your dog's belly flipped
and your dog is dead
then they're like oh that didn't work
people are still all right i guess we'll
just ban it but they tried they really
take it but like if you've been watching
the situation closely it doesn't seem so
necessary i don't know why why it has to
be this way my one airline just one
won't stand up and say we will take your
animals and i understand i mean they
said there was a lot of incidents and
accidents and biting happening honestly
with people's dogs on the planes but
what about for those of us who didn't
have those incidents in action yes also
why must we all be punished i'm just
waiting for one
person one wealthy person to start an
airline
and it should just be called humane
airlines where we respect people we
respect their property we respect their
feelings we respect their pets and their
and their personal space so it's an
airline where you pay slightly more not
anything crazy
slightly more for just really every row
should be too
decently sized recliners like this three
also like we're living in america like
not everyone can fit in those seats like
i just think two big recliners per i'm
not even asking for anything so crazy i
don't need a lay flat bed everywhere we
go but i just need an airline called
humane airlines where you can bring your
pets we won't be rude you won't you
can't be rude either though that's a
thing it's a social contract because
some don't get me wrong some people some
people but these days but these days
like when you see the viral airline
videos it's the airlines
no
these days when you see those viral
literally people i saw the craziest
video this guy had to be this guy had to
be sedated and taped to his chair it's
the passengers no i don't agree with
that at all oh no i think it's the
airlines like your two-year-old can't
keep their mask on he has asthma and
then kicked off the flight that's
moronic i'm not talking about that i'm
talking about like people literally like
starting fights i see the craziest [ __ ]
like people
i don't even know like i just see all
over tick-tock like people acting like
animals and like getting thrown out of
the plane and that's tick tock stuff
sure delaying the flights like people
just trying to get home to see their
family delaying for three hours because
like you are fighting with the person
next to you because of like elbow room
like it's so stupid you those people we
are separating them i don't want them
here okay i do not want them here also
on humane airlines might i suggest my
very ergonomic theory for airplane seats
instead of three and three
we get two two two
that way everybody's on an aisle
everybody's happy
nobody's in a middle seat okay i also
saw on tick tock this rendering it was
like a possible idea for how to lay out
a plane and it was pretty genius
so
i can't really explain it okay so it's
two
and then
behind you there's like a set of like
three stairs and then another two above
you so that you can lay flat on top like
a bunk bed almost
interesting it sounds like a
concentration camp when i say it but if
i show you this rendering like it
actually looked pretty fabulous okay
show me the rendering i want to look at
the plans i've got to start saving my
tic tocs like i can't remember i'll find
it but i agree like you i'll start a
gofundme for humane airlines as long as
we can get like some fortune 500 ceo to
run it like i'm [ __ ] done yeah no i
agree with you it's
it's gotten to be too much too much
now are you ready for our fifth and
final story oh my god already yeah yeah
oh wait sorry no no no you're not ready
i didn't know if you wanted a little
musical performance it's the final story
[Music]
[Applause]
wait you can bring your
punch
that's really good
okay our fifth and final story facebook
is pausing work on instagram kids app
amid growing scrutiny yeah i think
that's best i think that's best facebook
has announced that it's pausing its
instagram kids project in order to quote
work with parents experts and policy
makers to demonstrate the value and need
for this product the announcement
follows criticism from 44 state
attorneys general who asked facebook to
abandon the project and a request
request from democratic lawmakers for
more detail about the project you guys
yeah it's such a weird idea like how
about permanent pause you know dissolve
the branch these kids are already not
okay we've as we've demonstrated on the
show so many times no one it's like
we're already so worried about like what
for as long as i can remember like you
know be careful who you talk to on the
internet
and what we're gonna make a platform
just for kids so like people who are
freaks like know exactly where to go oh
i wasn't even thinking about that aspect
like how to catch a predator go on
instagram kids right
but i'm thinking about like the social
dilemma of course aren't okay the
campers have anxiety the campers don't
know how to socialize and these kids
need to get off their phones not have
reasons to spend more time using
technology here's an idea go outside
completely you're like so michelle obama
like get up get out get healthy 100 no
100 by the way these kids
are not well and i think that the this
is giving me very much vibes of like the
activists like who thought producing
this app producing this television show
would be a good idea and then like i
love when they announce it like we all
have a normal human reaction we're like
what the [ __ ] so problematic for so many
reasons and i'm so here for the
cancellation of kids to gram i don't
know what it was going to be called but
very much here for the cancellation very
and i don't believe in cancer culture
but very much it's a pause it's pause
culture permanent pause permanent pause
let's just not forget the permanent i
just really hope they don't come back to
this like i just hope that they can find
a dignified way to say you know we
[ __ ] up let's just you know what it's
okay if they never it's okay to make
mistakes if they never bring it up again
i will never bring it up again you know
like i don't want to be embarrassed
i will never talk about this again
pending that this pause is just like we
all just forget about it you know i
totally agree we need to focus on what
the kids actually need they need more
counselors the counselors they they need
actual like guidance counselors
counselors in bunks counselors and monks
we need to renovate the bunks and we
need to get the kids out like the kids
i really like
these kids are not well like i think
they've all been cooped up inside their
house for a year in addition to like all
of what happened before
social media being a kid comparing
yourself kid things for for generations
then they've been stuck with their
parents for a year not seeing their
friends not going to school not going to
their soccer practice during these
developmental years it's not like i just
didn't see my friends from 25 years old
like and i'm you know living with myself
and like fully developed like
the kids you guys i mean you're worried
about the kids this cannot go forward no
and this will be truly like the straw
that breaks the kids back yeah and the
campers cannot be walking around with
broken backs the campers can't sustain
much more they cannot
so that's what's the latest with the
campers um so yeah justice for the
campers justice for the girls and those
were our stories those were our stories
feels so you needed to know them and now
tv recap yes okay so i watched so much
cable television yesterday because we
were talking about last week how we both
wanted to start watching the voice
and then it was just on and i was
flipping through channels and so it was
dancing with the stars
and the recap of dancing with the stars
and the voice is brought to you by
overland
i'm excited me too i love overland you
got to tell them what it is then i gotta
share my experience there isn't yo you
have you have a story um yeah i've been
living in my overland there's nothing we
do every day that is comfier or more
luxurious than slipping into a pair of
overland sheepskin slippers they are a
family-owned american heritage brand
that puts comfort and quality first for
nearly 15 50 excuse me years they offer
outerwear accessories and home decor
that is all made from sustainable
natural fibers like sheepskin leather
and wool they use expert craftsmanship
to pair the highest quality merino
sheepskin which is naturally moisture
wicking temperature regulating and
antimicrobial with supportive memory
foam
in order to make slippers that feel
better and wear better for longer and
it's something that really sets overland
apart they're one of the only brands in
the world that use true double face
sheepskin so the suede you see on the
outside is the same piece as the fluffy
fluffy sheepskin you feel on the inside
you're getting top quality material
because it has to look and feel great to
meet all of their standards so i mean
you really cannot put a price on comfort
and actually wore my overland slippers
on the show last week and i got so many
compliments i'm obsessed i have the same
slippers that you have and they're
literally getting me so excited for fall
like can't think of anything better than
standing in those bad boys making chili
that's when you know that fall is here
you guys so slippers are so damn
comfortable and they have a nice grip at
the bottom so if you do find yourself
being over and leaving the house in them
it will be okay don't wait another day
to slip into something way more
comfortable get the best highest quality
sheepskin slippers on the market at
overland.com
toast and if you use that link you'll
get free shipping and free returns and
we recommend you go today because these
slippers are so beloved that they've
been very known to sell out that's
overland o-v-e-r-l-a-n-d
dot com slash toast overland.com
toast thank you claudia it's a pleasure
please share your experience i didn't
watch much tv last night okay so let me
just quickly get through the voice
because i'm obsessed
so i feel like i've watched the voice in
the past and it's always about the
contestants of course but like for me
there's so much star power on the
judging panel like i didn't even care
about the contestants like i was just
obsessed with watching them all like
banter and they all really have their
own
thing going on like the dynamic is
basically john legend is really quiet
like it's actually crazy how shy he is
i'm maybe not shy maybe introverted like
he's so quiet it's so
disarming it's just like not what i
expected from him
then there's ari who was like obviously
the most famous person there and like
they're always just like joking like if
ari turns around like they're never
gonna get the person that they want
because like who wouldn't want ari but
doesn't she have a maximum amount of
people she takes okay so but she's also
very selective so once she turns around
like it's over for everyone else and
they all just like start crying and
they're just like talking about how
famous she is the whole time and she's
like so humble she's like oh my god what
are you guys talking about like you're
kelly clarkson like you're like sheldon
like you're john legend like she's so we
we stand a humble queen and then blake
is obviously like his no like annoying
self but it's actually quite endearing
and he's just very funny and then
kelly's a [ __ ] queen and i just like
love her so [ __ ] much and she just
wants to like help her her team like so
bad and you just love to see
people out here respecting kelly
clarkson and for the most part they
really do i do wonder how it works
because obviously like if people turn
like
you know
someone turns around and like
you want them but they need to even out
like the teams like you have to go with
kelly even though like you wanted blake
or something like i wonder how that
works what do you mean like
because not everyone can go on one team
so like you can't
like they have to spread out like where
people go
no but like kelly wouldn't turn around
if she didn't have any more spots left
no i know but like let's say kel kelly
has like this fly is terrorizing me
let's say kelly has like one person on
her team and ariana has like four out of
five like they have like spread it out
you know what i mean well that's up to
ari if she doesn't want to fill her last
spot with this singer she just feels
like it feels like they're spreading it
out on the show that's all i'm saying
okay but i feel like as a judge you
would want to spread it out yourself
like this this singer better be the best
thing i've ever heard if they're gonna
take my fifth spot it's easier to get
ari's first spot than her fifth spot i
just feel like they're spreading it out
okay and there was two people last night
who got like all four chairs to turn one
was like cutie okay by the way you would
have loved him he's like from tennessee
he's obsessed with playing the fiddle he
got like so famous playing the fiddle
like in his town that ricky skriggs who
i think is like a really famous
bluegrass singer asked this kid to open
for him at the opry and it was like the
highlight of his life his dad starts
talking about watching his son play the
opera they start crying like i'm telling
you i was hysterically crying but he
also loves to sing and he came out and
saying this country song which i didn't
know it's called tulsa time which was
like annoying because whenever people
don't sing songs i know like it just
makes it worse but everyone turned
around for him and of course he went
with blake and it was like so cute
that's so cute and then this girl came
out she's saying rocket man by elton
john and everyone turned around
it was
spectacular like i was i had chills down
my spine i have a question who do you
think ari is taking the most contestants
from because like kelly oh you think
people who would normally go to kelly
are now choosing they really are very
similar they're like belty queens like
with oh crazy vocal range
and they're both like pop
interesting
like tough like i don't feel like ari's
taking people from blake like that
fiddler wasn't choosing ours never like
so blake is so country john legend is so
r b soul
ari and
kelly are both pop queens and they're
both known for their like unbelievable
vocal range so for me like if i was
going on like i would have a hard time
choosing between kelly and aria who
would you choose i think i would choose
kelly and this is why
i think ari has the best voice ever and
i think that like she was just born with
it and i think kelly has an amazing
voice but has trained her voice over the
years so much to like hit notes and work
on her breathing and i feel like that's
the kind of help i could use like it's
so like maybe i don't know this to be a
fact it just feels like it's so easy for
arya and i feel like kelly like works at
her talent yes and also i think kelly
has had to work harder to
make a space for herself like in the pop
world i mean there were so many albums
that she did with for labels that like
just didn't understand her like
story brand person you know she always
talks about like the some of the albums
that she made that like she had no
control over and i just feel like arie
was like born to be a pop star exactly
like i feel like kelly's just had a hard
time until recently honestly like
finding her space in this industry yeah
no it's extremely recent it's just and
so i don't know i just feel like i love
someone who struggles like everything in
ari's life is just like it all happened
so fast you know she was nickelodeon and
she was the biggest pop star in the
world like i just feel like i would
relate more to kelly's musical and
professional journey i agree with that
who would you choose i would choose
kelly because you know i just want to
get to know her see what she's all about
um i do think that actually like ari
like she's literally our age and has all
the same interests and like we would be
best best friends but in terms of a
coach like kelly gives me counselor
energy okay but then there's also this
thing where it's like okay if you're a
country singer yeah of course you want
to be mentored by blake but then you're
also like competing against all the
countries all the other country singers
so when ari and like kelly were trying
to persuade this fiddle kid they're like
okay obviously blake is obvious choice
but do you really want to we don't have
anyone country on my team like you would
be the the country and when you go into
the ring the battle rounds yeah it's not
country on country exactly so i actually
kind of agree with that they make a lot
of good points it sounds like no and
it's so
[ __ ] funny like oh basically blake
shelton says that he's like old enough
to be ariana grande's grandfather and
they just keep calling him grandpa it's
just they have the best banter it's so
premium and i just never really thought
i would be like a girl who watches the
voice i feel like i'm officially like
an old person i feel like old people
watch a voice old and young i think
now yeah no she is earning her keep like
she said she would bring in a new demo
and here you are and here i am and she's
excellent she's so sweet to like
everyone she's funny
she's great like i think that these four
should be on the show forever wow like i
don't ever and i remember i used to
watch with adam levine i found him to be
annoying i know people really liked him
i'm
i'm not glad he's gone but like i
wouldn't be watching if it was him like
these four are perfect oh my god i have
to watch it's so good jackie you will
love it and the singing like this girl
who's saying rocket man all four turn
around i believe she chose ari she was
i've never heard a voice like that in my
life like yes unbelievable i think i
recorded them so i'll watch you also you
can just watch them all on youtube
okay then i watched
dancing with the stars dancing with the
stars so there was a lot to unpack and
honestly i got
so bored by the end i didn't even watch
you got eliminated i believe christine
frimbling empire went home no she didn't
um the guy from cobra kai oh okay martin
rove martin cove i think um i was
watching and i'm like obviously he's the
one who goes on first only because like
it's so hard to dance
compete with everyone when you're that
much older
and
i've never heard of this man so it was
his time i thought i saw christine went
home okay nevermind nevermind so here's
what happened
cheryl burke
who was partners with cody rigsby tested
positive yeah and they had just been
together so he couldn't go to the
ballroom but they are gonna let him
still compete i don't know with who but
i'm sure he's quarantined for like a
little while
and we watched their performance that
they had in dress rehearsal which was
like them in their studio and it was
it was dark like it was not but with
chucks it was such a well choreographed
routine and cody's like so good i would
have loved to have seen that on the
ballroom like it was so high energy they
danced to
i think they danced to camilla caballo
oh yeah don't go yet
don't which i really like that song
so we did miss out on that like for sure
um
and everyone is just like getting really
good i'm sorry olivia jade is very good
and like her and her partner have
amazing chemistry is he married
he's dating someone on the couch or he's
married to someone that's on the cast
that's too bad because there's a lot i
think so chemistry between them let me
just i think her part her partner's val
chairmakovsky but there was someone else
on the cast with churkovsky i know
that's why it's confusing
so
i think he's married to pacha
no
he's married to jenna johnson
who's partners with jojo siwa okay jojo
siwa was okay she was good
she was fine she was good but
she was just fine like for a dance mom
amanda klutz was
unbelievably radiant and gorgeous like
she did this gorgeous dance like a frank
sinatra song it was so elegant so old
hollywood so everything of the sort and
she's such a good dancer it's like not
[ __ ] fair who cut the best scores oh
i don't know the scoring is so
irrelevant to me and let me tell you why
because somebody will do like good if
they're like a really bad dancer it's
like great on a curve you're saying it's
graded for no not even on a crypt graded
for the person okay so like
if i'm like a bad dancer but like martin
rose 10 is different than am amanda
klutz is 10. so right so i'm like
someone who's a bad dancer but this time
i kept up with all the steps i didn't
like drop anything but i wasn't
obviously like giving it you know the
best technique ever i'll get a seven but
then like amanda cloots who's like very
talented like they'll point out her
footwork problems yeah and she'll get a
six yeah so it makes no [ __ ] sense
okay but it also makes it a little bit
more fair because otherwise amanda's
getting a 10 every time if we're all
graded
on the same scale well it's dancing with
the stars not
dancing with the scale teaching with the
stars like yeah sorry i have to think
about how i think how how i think it
should go but christine from bling
empire
basically said she's obsessed with
dancing with the stars she's every year
like since she moved to la like she used
to enter in a lottery to win tickets
she's been they had footage of her
sitting behind the judges like 10 years
ago she was literally saying like this
is the dream of her life
she is not great like she just i feel
like she reminds me of someone she's
coordinated but has no rhythm which is
so hard to learn you know yeah yeah so
she was just giving me like low energy
but she was having so much fun like i
just want her to spend a good amount of
time there because i want her to have
fun
jimmy allen is so good but again it's so
easy for a boy to be good like he's very
much giving me like leading man energy
where like his partner's doing all the
dance work he's just like carrying her
around whereas like cody and
cheryl like they're both like salsa-ing
like going giving it the most like he
loves it you know yeah um and who else
was remarkable
melora hardin from the office jacqueline
she's so good i just like
i love her how was matt james
not good
he got bad scores and they like roasted
him um
and i was reading on twitter people were
like coming for him like for his
roomba like whatever it just it needs
work it's still only week two and to be
honest like for a while it's just a
popularity contest like there are a
bunch of people who need to go home
before anyone who has like a substantial
instagram following
is gonna go home and then it really
becomes about the scale yeah like for
now like we you just know so for now
like you do want to see growth so having
a bad week in the beginning like will
ultimately make your final dance look
better oh you know who i thought was
good it was iman shumpert he's like not
the best dancer but he was having so
much fun and he remembered all the steps
and i think that he was really
surprising and then also they're gonna
keep them on for a while because lebron
james watched dancing with the stars
last night and tweeted and they like
commented on it on air they're like
lebron james is watching it was like
crazy oh that's cool for them yeah and
tyra was like out here wearing crazy
[ __ ] outfits but doing much better
than last season like people are a
little too hard on her like i was i
wanted to see what people thought of
like everything and i was on twitter and
people are just [ __ ] hard on ty we're
like yeah she was bringing the craziest
stupidest dress you've ever saw in your
life
but like leave leave her alone like it's
it's a moment she's a model yeah
cool well that sounds like very good it
sounds very good um okay did you watch
any tv you want to recap i did and i
just watched a little outlander but i
was mostly editing the mukbang so i was
just watching patreon.com morning toast
all night and i have to say it was
premium content i would recommend to
anyone all right let's dive into your
toasters our advice segment which we do
every tuesday and if you ever want to
write in it's dear toasters gmail.com
and we will always keep your [ __ ]
anonymous here's the first one hi
claudia and jackie i love you guys so
much congrats on your bed jax and
claudia congrats for simply being you
which is fabulous wow that's pathetic no
i thought that was like you've
accomplished so much and like i'm just
like over here it's fine
i'm not sure i don't this is about her i
don't want to make the deer treasures
about me but it like you obviously feel
but it is
i loved your toasters and i never
thought i need to write in but i'm torn
and i need your input input on what to
do for the past year my best friends and
i have gotten together to get group
gifts for each other with the idea being
that putting our money together for one
big gift would be better than giving
each other small inexpensive gifts and
it would likely be something that we
would all like to have like a designer
piece of jewelry or accessory it was
finally my turn and i was so excited to
get my gift my birthday comes around and
i get a hodgepodge of items from amazon
with a total value of half of what i've
coordinated and gotten with everyone
else i know this because your girl got
gift receipts i naturally was bummed
because i was excited to get a nice new
item and instead i got items of
significantly less value
and things i've never even asked for nor
wanted having the money is definitely
not the issue here so i'm not quite sure
why i didn't get a nice present when
we've been putting in this gift-giving
trend for a year i know you should never
expect anything in return but i just
feel like i lef i just feel left out and
i'm not sure why my friends didn't spend
the money on me so here's my dilemma
it's time for the next girly girl to get
her gift do i continue on and coordinate
for her to get the same big ticket item
i've coordinated for the rest of the
girls in the past and be a good friend
or do i mention anything about my
lackluster gift please help sincerely a
disappointed best friend who's trying
really hard not to be petty oh my this
would bother the [ __ ] out of me this
would rather be so much especially
because there's not that much that you
can do without looking like a slob yeah
and like that you're like counting
everyone and like
you know they did get you a gift
no but like a designer piece of jewelry
and things from amazon that's like a
crazy difference yeah no you
you have to put your foot down you can't
be a schmuck i'm sorry yeah you can't
just be like steamrolled over no and
just like keep buying everyone all of
these things and like why didn't they
well the reason actually why they didn't
get it for you is because you coordinate
it for everyone else
so let someone else coordinate this time
and see what see what happens i think
that's why because i don't want to say
like they like you less and and you know
i because that seems too obvious yeah i
think it's because someone else got put
in charge they waited till the last
minute and they sent you some [ __ ] from
prime overnight and they've been used to
you like
yeah i think that's what happened here
don't take charge that's the answer here
do not take charge
hello hi thank you thank you
oh it's raining out there
stay dry
have a good one
we got a package sorry those from the
postman it's fragile on it and it has a
photo of brew on it should we do a live
unboxing yeah because i think it's from
this brand that um had dm me they they
put together some mock-ups of some
things they wanted to send me and it was
some of the most incredible looking
stuff because it was like all brew merch
this is not an ad
it was all brew merch and they really
captured his likeness and so i was like
i would love to receive these items did
it occur to you at any moment to get
something for your nephew they didn't
they didn't mock up do and i didn't want
to be um
like a gaza so
i just accepted what they had for me
just watch out for the patrick
okay first up i hope you guys are
watching on youtube too yeah no this is
about to be some of the most premium
[ __ ] we've ever seen oh
my god
oh my god now i know what i didn't get
anything it's for babies
okay here are two bibs ready
it has a picture of bruno on it and it
says bruno
oh my god give that to me and then
there's also onesie not a bib oh sorry
then there's also this one that says
best friends
and there is a bib sorry that's why i
got confused this bib oh my god it just
has a picture of bruno
look look at this hand-drawn picture of
bruno they completely captured his
likeness
completely captured
there's so much more stuff by the way
this company is not an ad and there's
some stuff for me in there too like a
crew neck i remember turkey prince it's
called perky prince and they will
capture your pup's likeness masks with
bruno on it i'm dying
do you want to be unboxing this i just
felt like you didn't worry you're doing
a great job oh my god a gorgeous t-shirt
with
bruno you guessed it
hold on there's more this is the crew
neck this is actually sick
hand-drawn bruno facemen oh my god this
is sick that is [ __ ] sick thank you
perky prince wait there's one more big
thing oh my god is it
this i think is gonna be
where's my
oh my goodness
oh
okay
oh
oh my god this is the cutest [ __ ]
company
thank you johnny oh
my god
oh my god we finally have our first
piece of brew art this is gorgeous that
is gorgeous oh my god what a great time
for the postman to come hey
wait a
oh my god this is so beautiful it's like
i wanna hang it in the studio you know
because we have so much theo art here
but this is theo's place okay
but you need it for your house i need i
don't you like you have a wall of field
at home too so i just need to get
started on my
brew memorabilia i can't believe that's
a hand like sketched sketch of brew
that's and you know he's got like all of
his little baby hairs and his little
freckle on his like nose and his
numerous freckles and his just
the look of love in his eye they got
that too so you can get these at
perkyprints.com at perky prince and then
hashtag perky again not an adjective
just great timing and a great product
and they had the picture of brew on the
box otherwise we probably wouldn't have
opened it live okay so back to this girl
who um
is getting legs and sorry to like open
all these gifts for me when your issue
is rubbing it in her face okay but here
i think that you need to drop the ball
now you need to because it hurts too
much
and fool me once shame on you fool me
twice and just say where do i send the
venmo like do not be in charge and see
what happens like if they're now going
back to designer duds then you know it's
not because you're not in charge there's
another reason that we might have to
face but let's not get let's not jump to
any conclusions yeah but i think it's
time for you to relinquish your duties
as you were not respected and you're not
gonna put up with that you're not a
doormat i'm i'm unfortunately in
agreement all right next up but i don't
think it's because they don't like you
so that's good news no but we'll see
like what happens next like yeah i don't
i don't want to bring that of course no
after you relinquish then they'll get
their [ __ ] together still i don't think
it's because they didn't like you i
think it's because they didn't have
their [ __ ] together okay
next up dear claudia and jackie first
off i could literally not survive the
week without my daily dose of morning
toast side note i took a road trip with
my fiance two weeks ago and he fell
asleep and was abruptly woken up too
it's the final story
anyway i'm currently planning my
bachelorette party and i'm in a bit of a
predicament surrounding the guest list i
have 10 bridesmaids my three sisters and
i are best friends and they make up much
of the bridal party but i wouldn't have
it any other way the rest of my bridal
party some of my best friends some of
the best friends a girl could truly ask
for on top of that i plan on having my
mom and a few other close relatives
there i'm so sorry i wasn't listening at
all oh god i'm really sorry i was just
thinking about the brew items we
received i'm currently planning my
bachelorette party and i'm in a bit of a
predicament i have ten bridesmaids my
three sisters and i are best friends and
they make up much of the bridal party
but i wouldn't have it any other way
okay the rest of my brother party is
some of the best friends a girl could
truly ask for and then on top of that
for the bachelorette party i plan on
having my mom and a few other close
relatives there cute my issue is that
i've had other people who are not in the
wedding reach out asking me when the
bachelorette party will be some people
who are these people these people need
to get together and have their own party
no and like we need to like send them
you know
a presentation a cease and desist as to
how you behave in as a human being as a
human being so when you get invited to a
wedding these are friends that i may not
see that often but we do speak every day
or every week i do suffer from a bit of
social anxiety so events like this
already make me anxious i worry a lot
about making sure everyone else is
having a great time and i don't love
everything being all about me i hate the
idea of anyone being upset with me if
they are not invited considering i do
talk to these people often when they ask
me what it is i usually just tell them
we're still planning my question is will
i regret not inviting everyone and just
anyone to such a special event or should
i just keep it to my close group of
people if i don't invite them what's the
best way of going about telling them
since i already have a larger bridal
party that i'm just gonna keep it small
sincerely a social anxious who wants to
please every bride and toaster okay um
if you weren't planning on inviting them
they didn't come across your mind even
though you said you were inviting people
who aren't bridesmaids then they
shouldn't be there and you shouldn't
just invite them because you feel
pressure and because you don't want to
be the awkward of saying no like you
just need to put together like a text
that says what it needs to say which is
that in a polite way you know i'm so
like honored that you would want to go
on this trip for my bridal party but i'm
just keeping it to uh bridesmaids only
and family members so
maybe these people don't know they're
not probably like how do you say so
not you so here i want to say one thing
with bachelorette parties i'm very much
of the mind that truly the more the
merrier like i agree and so i know
that's not for everyone but having done
a bachelorette party where i had i just
invited everyone even people who weren't
bridesmaids because it's really the more
fun people
wanted to not because they reached out
and made you feel uncomfortable but i
just want to just say that like
i think bachelorette parties the more
people the more successful
one two if someone is willing because
sometimes with a bachelorette party it's
like people don't want to pay if
somebody's willing to pay to join you to
have fun i'm more inclined to be like
sure come so that's just what i want to
say think about that like if you if you
think that like you actually really like
these people and it's like tough for you
not to invite them like sometimes not a
bachelorette party like you'll be glad
the more people you invite so i just
want to put that out i do agree with you
but if you decide that you don't want
them
then we must concoct a plan yeah and i
just think it's like just honesty is the
best policy yes i already
like have a big group going and just
like keep keeping to like delaying it is
not helpful yeah say like thank you for
like even wanting to come that's so
sweet of you but i'm just keeping it to
brian's amazing family you know because
my mom's coming like you know i love
blaming things like blaming on your mom
like my mom's coming so it's only going
to be like a couple girls like no but
it's she's going to see pictures she's
10 plus
so just invite these girls no because
you didn't think about that she talks to
them every day she said once a week i
thought she said she said
she said
these are friends that i may not see
often but we do speak every day or every
week so we're both right
that is what it looks like
um okay think about it if you think
these girls would add value to your trip
just invite them and then you don't have
to deal with the awkwardness of turning
them down it's no expense to you but
also this is a time in your life to be
selfish
and
do if you don't want them coming for
whatever reason
just say like i'm keeping it to
bridesmaids thank you though for even
like
wanting to celebrate me yeah yeah yeah
um okay i hope that was helpful just
invite them third and final dear
toasters is brought to you by bruce the
best electric toothbrush
we should have this company make us
kernex with a bruce on it a hundred
percent so bruce is the best electric
toothbrush on the market and the
official morning toast tooth brush every
toaster pretty much has their morning
their brush and if you don't let me tell
you why it's worth it first of all so
many electric toothbrushes can cost over
200
which is just outrageous but oral care
is important and bruce is out here
bringing you the best electric
toothbrush and it's super affordable
compared to those in the market and they
also come in like stunning beautiful and
smart colors that will just like make
you look fabulous you can get like a
cool one for your boyfriend one for you
one for your girlfriend like
it's just everything of the sort the
battery life lasts four weeks so you
could travel with it and the brush has
six unique modes of vibrations
electricity
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again they'll ship you a new
replacement head every six months so
you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head their electric toothbrush has
a modern aesthetically pleasing design
that comes in trend driven seasonal
colors and it looks great on your
bathroom counter get 15 off your bruised
toothbrush kit and the refill plan when
you use code toast at bruce.com that's
15 off using promo code toast at
b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com
fifteen dollars off using promo code
toast b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
that's so cute okay you want to hear the
third and final one
yes i do i hope this one is i hope we
can do better for this one than we've
done for the first two i'm not gonna lie
we've given some wishy-washy i think
that the advice i gave in the last one
was actually good like just invite like
you'll never regret inviting like a
bunch of friends somewhere you know what
i mean like you will regret not inviting
if like let's say in five years you end
up being really close with one of these
you know what i mean like just invite i
think that's actually good advice this
one is actually not addressed to just us
it's dear jackie claudia doctor do and
i need your advice voice and i've
included the boys because i would love a
male perspective as well she needs her
voice what she needs hard voice she's
our voice
never mind
you guys heard it yeah i know but i i
guess let you out
i guess let you out of it
yes i'm like what are you talking about
she needs our advice and she included
the boys because she would have a male
person which i thought of that she would
include she wants to include a male
perspective okay okay when it comes to
dating i've always been super picky i
usually know right away whether i can
see a future with someone or not the
problem is when i do find a guy i'm
interested in i fall fast and hard and
get my heart broken by someone i've
known for a month it's pathetic i know
no it's not
flashback to two years ago i go on a
date with a guy i met on hinge i did not
have that first initial obsessive all-in
feeling that i usually get with guys
that i'm interested in but i figured i
would give him a chance because he
honestly looks good on paper and is
super attractive and leaning into that
initial intense spark i've had with guys
in the past has only left me heartbroken
i love you changing things up and talk
about being self-fucking aware yeah like
knowing what you're good at what you're
not good at and acting change like i'm
yeah i think
this course of action hurt you in the
past i'm gonna try something different
you know get out of my comfort zone
exactly so we go on a few dates over the
span of a month or so and i really like
him he's smart has a great job and has a
wonderful group of friends and is the
cutest dog in the world other than doing
bro okay we make the relationship
official after two months but i still
don't feel that spark flash forward to
the present we just celebrated our
two-year anniversary and things are
going great so i'm assuming you feel the
spark our lives fit per no i think the
problem is that she doesn't our lives
sparkles for two years why don't you let
me finish and we can find out our lives
fit perfectly together and we talk about
getting engaged in our future the only
problem is i still don't feel that spark
i even feel like we skipped the whole
honeymoon phase because i wasn't head
over heels for him i really love him and
our life is great but i'm just worried
he's not the one am i watching too many
couples on tick tock and being overly
critical of my own relationship watch
downton abbey or should i throw all of
this away in the hopes of finding mr
right please help and unsure toaster
this girl's so smart like she knows
what she's feeling might be irrational
and you know what i'm here to tell you
like i do think it is
i said i really love him i have some
advice that i don't that's probably
gonna sound like the wrong advice but
just hear me out okay
because of course like you should feel
spark and love and honeymoon phase but
really most of the couples that have all
of that it doesn't equate to long-term
success or a successful marriage yeah
and so the things that you guys have in
common even though it did sound like a
little superficial but maybe i'm
assuming there's more if there's two
years worth of relationship here the
things that you guys have in common are
a really good foundation for a marriage
which is about more than spark because
as we've said those butterflies up and
leave in two [ __ ] months and they try
straight into gas and they don't come
back and honestly i think like if you're
spending your whole life chasing a spark
like that's not a realistic way of
ending up in a long-term relationship
relationships marriage commitment is
about so much more than spark it's about
partnership it's compatibility
communication support belief in the same
thing
value
philosophical yep so when you say like
that you don't have a spark but you
respect this man and you've found a way
to spend all your time with him for two
years you love him very much that's
literally what she said
i say
that that's a pretty good foundation for
marriage
and when you think about like downton
abbey you know and all these marriages
that were
arranged marriages like so many years
ago where you know at first there was no
spark and there probably wasn't going to
be spark for a long time but eventually
there was love right and you fall so
deeply in love with each other every day
every year and you know what that
reminds me of indian matchmaking yes
they started every episode of the show
with this cup with like a different
couple who was you know really old
school arranged marriage and they were
some of like the healthiest funniest
couples i ever saw in my life not saying
that this is an arranged marriage but
all i'm saying is like watching so many
movies and books like you're supposed to
think that like you meet someone in that
second you get the spark and you just
know and that's really like not how
realistic marriages work so i do think
we've become like fan like we just
fantasize and we've been like taught
that a relationship is supposed to start
and end in this one way when at the end
of the day that's just like not
realistic yeah and that's my opinion i
agree i think you should marry this man
i think you should marry this man and
just to let us know like if we're right
in our hypothesis yeah like this could
be the stuff of a really long-term
successful marriage and i wish you
honestly the best of luck with that
because
not many people have it but it really
sounds all really fabulous and you sound
like a great girl with like such a great
head on her shoulders yeah
love that for you that was your toasters
our advice segment so if you ever want
to write in if you're having a problem
you want our fabulous advice on dear
toasters gmail.com and if you've written
in and we have read your prompt on air
and you either followed or did not
follow our advice we would love to hear
an update from you deartoasters
gmail.com with an update please
that's our show anything you want to say
before i wrap up no i mean
it's been a journey this show
and it's been a pleasure as well it's
been a pleasure and i hope everyone has
an amazing day go watch our mukbang at
patreon.com morning toast and we will
see you tomorrow thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public video i already
cast box all the places so whatever you
listen to podcast find out the morning
toast leave a five star review about
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an amazing day and if
you've made it to the end of this
episode congratulations you are now a
member of the society season two and to
let us know that you are true toaster
who listens to the end of the episode
because you care about what we have to
say drop an emoji on our most recent
instagram drop the emoji of um
[Music]
there's so many things from today
what's it going to be the witch like
something witchy give me the witchy
vibes
yeah yeah a witchy vibe a potion a
crystal ball a cauldron
jinx have a great day everyone will see
you tomorrow bye